he is a child killer
a murderer of 51 innocents
a white supremacist for the christ
church
terrorist a record sentence
you will now stand on each of the 51
charges of murder
charges 1-51 you are sentenced to life
imprisonment
order that you serve the sentences
without parole
on each of the 40 charges of attempted
murder charges 52-91
he was sentenced to concurrent terms of
12 years in prison
on the charge of committing a terrorist
act charge 92
you were sentenced to life imprisonment
[Applause]
this is the first time in new zealand's
history
anyone has been given life without
parole
it was a big relief for all of us and
we all happy what he deserved we got and
what we deserve we got
justice is done as imam says no justice
is enough for those one
you know they lost their family member
and loved one
but at least something is done that take
the pain
and take the the lord we had in our
heart
from us cold and calculating
in 2019 brenton tarrant slaughtered
worshipers
at two mosques in christchurch he
executed a three-year-old
then reloaded there was no mercy
no remorse his sentence reflects that
he deliberately killed a three-year-old
infant by shooting him in the head as he
clanged to the league of his father
the terror you inflicted in the last few
minutes of that small child's life
is but one instance of the pitiless
cruelty
that you exhibited throughout new
zealand grieved as one the prime
minister
held the heart broken in their darkest
hour
today she welcomed the punishment of a
mass
murderer this has been a crime in new
zealand that has never the likes of
which has never occurred before
and now we've seen a sentence the likes
of which we've never seen before as well
um but yes it gave me relief to know
that that person will never see the
light of day
isolation in a maximum security prison
awaits the terrorist his cruelty and
crimes have exposed the very worst of
humanity
in the survivors the very best
they now have legal justice
[Music]
they may never find peace
siobhan robbins sky news